l'habitation la sucrerie domine le bourg
désinstaller depuis deux siècles les
deux le site récemment restaurée est
classé au niveau historique accueille
tout ce week-end un atelier de
couverture artisanale et c'est christian
chéri le seul professionnel de lille qui
explique ces techniques amérindienne
encore pratiquée aujourd'hui elle à
devenir artisan utilise la feuille de
cannes bien mûr qui se détache tout seul
du plan il faut une cinquantaine de
feuilles pour constituer ce que l'on
appelle un bouchon s'est attaché avec la
paye même et après on a on va le monter
sur le toit sur les couvertures quand
j'ai déjà vu
j'ai vu à la savane des esclaves et je
suis intéressé pensable que j'aimais
bien points comme beaucoup de visiteurs
marilyn veut essayer et l'atelier est
précisément là pour ça j'adore ça parce
que les gens ils sont aviv 2
de connaissances et quand quand on leur
montre la moindre petite chose ici une
question ils adorent ils veulent toucher
ils veulent pas avec moi il n'était pas
et ça c'est un plaisir les liteaux sont
en bois thibault même putrescibles puis
j'ai rangé de paille superposés vont
assurer à la fois l'étanchéité et
l'isolation thermique naturelle si le
travail a bien fait de 3 pourra durer 5
à 15 ans avec un peu d'entretien toutes
les techniques les des 1 700 blessés
c'est une bonne chose parce qu'il m'a
dit que les amis d'hier une technique
les applications venu avec la leur donc
on a fusionné les deux pour faire avant
ce produit 50 feuilles par bouchon cinq
minutes pour faire un bouchon 18 bouchon
m je suis pas prêt d'avoir fait à toi
moi bois tressé et toits en paille
christian chéri exerce son art sur les
sites classés son plus grand rêve est de
transmettre ce savoir faire par le biais
de formations dans le cadre de
l'apprentissage socoa il disparaîtra
mais c'est peut-être sûrement
disparaître parce qu'elles vont
peut-être copier
regardez approximativement mais si on
n'a pas donné la technique de base au
fur et à mesure fil des années ben la
technique disparaîtra l'artisan à tout
ce week-end pour plaider sa cause
les centaines de visiteurs sont encore
attendus